[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Desiree
Millionen in Deutschland wollen kurz vor
Weihnachten und Silvester wissen wie es
in der Pandemie weitergeht was da auf
sie zukommt alles Wichtige dazu in den
nächsten 20 Minuten und damit herzlich
willkommen Kristin Otto ist wieder bei
mir wieder sowas ähnliches wie Gold
Glückwünsche von dir für einen Schwimmer
guten Abend und wir blicken auf die
Themen
Beschränkungen zum Jahresende Bund und
Länder beschließen im Kampf gegen
Omikron striktere Corona Maßnahmen auch
für geimpfte und Genesende
damit das Land nicht lahm liegt
Müllabfuhr Feuerwehr und Co bereiten
sich wegen Omicron auf deutliche
Personalausfälle vor
und mit Weltrekord zum Gold
Olympiasieger Florian Wellbrock
triumphiert auch bei der Kurzbahn WM in
Abu Dhabi
[Musik]
ja die Sorgen vor der 5. Welle sind groß
das liegt am neuesten Gesicht der
Pandemie an onikon bis eben hat die
Bund-Länder Runde über Maßnahmen
Verschärfungen beraten schon vor Beginn
des Treffens haben zwei Meldungen
aufhorchen lassen zum einen empfiehlt
die Ständige Impfkommission Booster
Impfungen wegen Omikron schon nach drei
anstatt sechs Monaten und zum anderen
spricht sich das Robert Koch Institut
für sofortige Verschärfungen aus und das
sind die Entscheidungen der Bund Länder
Runde die Bundeskanzler Scholz vor
wenigen Minuten bekannt gegeben hat und
die spätestens ab dem 28 Dezember gelten
sollen was private Kontakte angeht da
sollen sich nur noch maximal zehn
Menschen treffen dürfen für ungeimpfte
sind die Regeln dann noch strenger zum
Thema Veranstaltungen Sportevents wie
die Fußballbundesliga sowie große
Kulturveranstaltungen sollen ohne
Zuschauer stattfinden Clubs und Discos
schließen und zum Thema Impfungen hier
will man das hohe Tempo beibehalten bis
Ende Januar sollen 30 weitere Millionen
Dosen verändert werden mehr jetzt von
Ines Trams
das Krisentreffen es war einberufen
worden wegen der sich rasant ausbreiten
den Omikron Variante nach 3 Stunden wird
klar es wird Kontakt Beschränkungen
geben auch für genießen und geimpfte
allerdings erst nach Weihnachten
[Musik]
Expertenrat der Bundesregierung und der
besteht aus 19 Wissenschaftler und
Wissenschaftlerinnen und das RKI ist ein
Teil davon hatte eine einstimmige
Empfehlung abgegeben und an dieser
Empfehlung orientieren wir uns in
unserem Beschluss
CSU-Chef Söder hatte sich höchst
irritiert gezeigt ob der Vielstimmigkeit
wann sollen die Einschränkungen nun
greifen
Bundesgesundheitsminister hat noch am
Sonntag dies für Weihnachten
ausgeschlossen dass ihm unterstellt sie
Institut des RKI sagt das Gegenteil
also das muss heute noch mal aufgeklärt
und was ist jetzt die Aussage auch
Hamburg hatte zuvor angekündigt sein
eigenes Ding zu machen der Stadtstaat
führt bereits ab Weihnachten schärfere
Kontakt Beschränkungen 1
Geister Stadien geschlossene Clubs und
Bars den Grünen geht all das nicht weit
genug schon vor dem Treffen fordern Sie
wie die Union die epidemische Notlage
zurück
bestellen
ja mit Theo Koll in Berlin gibt es jetzt
viel zu besprechen Theo die Beschlüsse
sind relativ frisch wie sind sie zu
bewerten
nur sind milde Beschlüsse muss man sagen
die unions Länder waren eigentlich mit
einer Art Kampfansage in diese Sitzung
gezogen wenn auch eine milde Varianten
ihrer Beschlussvorlage hatten sie von
der Bundesregierung einen kurzfristigen
Zeitplan für die allgemeine in Pflicht
gefordert und eine konkrete Planung wie
auf der Grundlage der dramatischen
Warnung des Expertenrat ist die Omikron
Variante bekämpft bekämpft werden könnte
und man wollten in Aussicht gestellt
haben eine weitere MPK und das ist
offensichtlich jetzt passiert also
letzteres jedenfalls man wird sich am 7.
Januar wieder treffen aber bis dahin
gelten nur die milden Maßnahmen die im
Vorfeld schon besprochen worden waren
das heißt also ab 28 spätestens ab 28
Dezember wird auch für geimpfte die
maximale Obergrenze von 10 Menschen
gelten für Treffen das
Robert-Koch-Institut hat sie ja heute
Maßnahmen empfohlen die sich im
Gegensatz zum beschlusspapier von Bund
und Ländern und auch eben zu den
Beschlüssen wie so eine harte lok'tar
und Empfehlung lesen was bedeutet das
jetzt dieses Spannungsverhältnis also
das war heute eine echte Handgranate die
das RKI da in die Sitzung geworfen hat
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach ist offen
sie auch entsprechend sauer das sei
nicht abgestimmt und er soll sogar so
wurde mir jedenfalls berichtet
Konsequenzen angekündigt haben das ganze
ist auch deshalb so brisant weil die RKI
Forderungen also sofortige und maximale
Kontakt Beschränkung klar gegen die
Linie des Ministers gehen denn der hatte
ja einen Lover und vor Weihnachten
ausdrücklich ausgeschlossen
dementsprechend hat der Kanzler
offensichtlich auch den RKI Chefin der
Sitzung abgekanzelt vielleicht noch ganz
kurz zu der STIKO Empfehlung Theo
Booster Impfungen schon nach drei
anstatt 6 Monaten durchzuführen wie ist
das politisch zu bewerten ich glaube es
ist nicht wirklich politisch sonder geht
es darum sicherzustellen dass niemand
mehr abgewiesen wird wir hatten ja immer
wieder Fälle wo Menschen dann
zurückgewiesen worden weil ihr noch ein
paar Tage fehlten bis zu den fünf oder
sechs Monaten und das soll auf keinen
Fall passieren deswegen hat man gesagt
so viele wie möglich sollen gepostet
werden der Kanzler hat ja auch eben
angekündigt man wolle 30 Millionen
weitere Menschen im Januar impfen also
insofern muss man alle Hürden und
Hemmnisse abbauen danke für die
Hintergründe nach Berlin Theo Koll war
das und es wird auch deswegen so
eindringlich vor Omicron gewarnt weil
die Auswirkungen wegen der rasanten
Ausbrenner Ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit
so massiv sein können schon ein Omikron
Verdachtsfall kann dazu führen das ganze
Betriebe oder Schulklassen in Quarantäne
müssen wie z.b. aktuell in
Schleswig-Holstein Tom Paluch berichtet
gleich drei Klassen und knapp 20
Lehrkräfte sind hier am
Kopernikus-Gymnasium im Kreis Segeberg
in Quarantäne Omicron so der Verdacht
nach ersten Tests scheint auch hier
angekommen zu sein das Gesundheitsamt
ist deswegen noch vorsichtiger als sonst
und vorsorglich nur noch online
Unterricht hat sich wahnsinnig schnell
ausgebreitet sind wahnsinnig schnell
viele Menschen sozusagen infiziert und
positiv dann getestet wurden also das
ist was was glaube ich einfach dann
immer wieder passieren könnte dass man
sozusagen sehr schnell die Schulen
aufschließen muss experten fordern daher
weitergehende Maßnahmen auch wenn die
Inzidenzen momentan eher sinken die
berechtigte Sorge ist dass ich das sehr
schnell ändern kann und deswegen
präventiv jetzt schon Kontakte zu
beschränken um die Ausbreitung des Virus
zu vermeiden ist auf jeden Fall richtig
jetzt kommen die Weihnachtsferien die
Verunsicherung wie es im neuen Jahr
weitergeht ist groß
Schulen sind das eine was aber wenn
Omikron in wichtigen Bereichen zuschlägt
die unser Land am Laufen halten also in
der sogenannten kritischen Infrastruktur
dazu zählen unsere Energie und
Wasserversorgung der Transport und
Lebensmittel weg.de expert der
Bundesregierung warnen aber auch
eindringlich vor massiven Corona
Ausfällen bei Polizei und Feuerwehr wenn
nämlich zu viele Beschäftigte
gleichzeitig ausfallen drohen
Versorgungsengpässe und die Störung der
öffentlichen Sicherheit dazu Andreas
linke
das Heizkraftwerk in Stuttgart Münster
Infrastruktur in mehrfacher Hinsicht den
Restabfall der ganzen Region verbrennen
Sie hier damit bevor sie Turbinen die
Strom für weite Teile Stuttgart erzeugen
und sie haben ein Nebenprodukt die
Fernwärme mit der sie ganze Stadtteile
heizen nun aber könnte Omikron sie vor
Probleme stellen zwar dahingehend dass
so ein hoher Anteil Antoine Bevölkerung
und damit auch an Beschäftigten in
dieser kritischen Infrastruktur selbst
krank werden oder in Quarantäne müssen
und uns dann das Personal fehlt
12 bis 17 Mitarbeiter brauchen sie im
Kraftwerk Münster mindestens pro Schicht
bisher haben die strengen Corona
Maßnahmen absolut geholfen aber
Notfallszenarien werden zumindest
gedacht auch für Kontaktpersonen oder
Corona positive wenn sie natürlich
asymptomatisch also das heißt selber
nicht krank sind dann könnten wir sie
hier so isolieren mit Maske und allem
drum und dran separat essenstechnisch
versorgt dass diese Mensch dann
vollkommen isoliert ihre Arbeit
nachgehen könnten wenn das nur notwendig
wäre auch die Feuerwehr gehört zur
kritischen Infrastruktur auf die man
sich im Notfall gerne verlassen möchte
für die unterschiedlichen Bereiche
prüfen die Krisenstäbe unterschiedliche
Ideen wird denken dran wenn uns die
Feuerwehr wenn die Personal
Schwierigkeiten bekommt das mehrere
Gemeindefeuerwehren gleichzeitig
alarmiert werden zu einem Einsatz oder
dass die Feuerwehrfrauen und
Feuerwehrmänner nicht erst zum
Feuerwehrhaus fahren und dann zu 5 im
Fahrzeug sondern mit Privat-PKW
hinfahren für die Stuttgarter Feuerwehr
klingt das erstmal skurril aber irgendwo
im Land könnte Omikron auch das
erforderlich machen
ja wie ist auch kommt die hohen Corona
Inzidenzen drücken stark auf die
Kauflaune in Deutschland das geht aus
dem aktuellen Konsumklimaindex hervor
aber auch für die Gastro und
Eventbranche ist die Situation ziemlich
schwierig mit Mühe und Not haben sich
z.b. viele Club Betreiber so gerade über
Wasser halten können und jetzt geht das
ganze wieder von vorne los Ausgang
ungewiss Alexander röttig
solche Bilder wird es länger nicht geben
feiern in den Clubs vorbei bald folgen
womöglich Bars und Restaurants jüngere
müssen sich auf weitere magere Monate
einstellen ich glaube ja mal eine
Durststrecke und da warte mal Bock dass
man da rauskommt aber ja ein bisschen
auf die Zähne beißen und irgendwas rum
Chan nervig also dann versteht mit dem
Mund machen Muster weiß weshalb man
möchte halt auch verschiedene Kontakte
pflegen und irgendwie ist das seid zwar
ja nicht mehr so richtig möglich mach
mal vor dem Treffen in den Test und auch
wenn es keine 100% Gewissheit aus
versuchen wird es einfach so dass man
dann trotzdem Freunde und Familie
tracken kandidate betreibt in Düsseldorf
mehrere angesagte Clubs und Bars er hat
freiwillig 2G + eingeführt um
Infektionen zu vermeiden vergeblich er
befürchtet ein Clubsterben nicht nur
weil Umsätze fehlen
auch im letzten Jahr haben einige die
Flinte ins Korn geworfen und wir und ihr
Geschäft aufgegeben in erster Linie weil
es finanziell vorne und hinten nicht
hingehauen hat aber auch weil sie in and
mental nicht mehr in der Lage waren der
Festsaal der Düsseldorfer die Schenke
bleibt leer bei Thomas dams geworden
Weihnachtsessen für insgesamt tausend
Gäste abgesagt mit viel Liebe und
finanziellem Einsatz hat er im Juni an
Traditionslokal auf neuen Kurs gebracht
wenn er jetzt zumachen muss bleibt nur
eine Hoffnung ja eine schnelle und
sofortige Hilfe gerade wir die neu
aufgemacht haben natürlich keine
Rücklagen in der Höhe dass wir jetzt uns
ein wieder mal sechsmonatigen Lockdown
leisten können es kann irgend werden für
viele Bars Clubs und Restaurants
schließlich weiß niemand wie lange uns
die Pandemie im Griff hält
ja und während sich die 5. Welle weiter
aufbaut da gehen die Fallzahlen noch
zurück das Robert-Koch-Institut meldet
23000 428 Neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
Tages das sind
7395 weniger als am vergangenen Dienstag
außerdem wurden innerhalb von 24 Stunden
462 Todesfälle registriert die sieben
Tage Inzidenz singt auf nun 306,
ja das waren sehr viele wichtige Corona
Nachrichten am heutigen Tag Details zu
allen beschlossenen Maßnahmen finden Sie
auf ZDF heute bzw in unserer App mehr
dann auch in einem ZDF Spezial Omikron
und die Folgen gleich nach unserer
Sendung
regierende Bürgermeisterin von Berlin
diesen Titel gibt es so heute zum
allerersten Mal heute Mittag wurde
Franziska Giffey als erste Frau ins
höchste Amt der Berliner Landespolitik
gewählt ihr rot grün roter Senat
verspricht einen echten Neuanfang
Zukunft Hauptstadt soll Berlin werden im
Fokus massiver Investitionen in den
öffentlichen Nahverkehr und der
Wohnungsbau aus Berlin Stephan
Merseburger
ich schwöre es so wahr mir Gott helfe
euch
mit Gottesbezug Franziska Giffey wird
erst die regierende Bürgermeisterin von
Berlin die Sozialdemokratin koaliert
weiter mit Grünen und Linken verspricht
aber einen Neuanfang viele neue
Gesichter im Senat Frauen in der
Überzahl neben Giffey sechs Senator
innen und vier Senatoren
Sprengstoff für diese Koalition
die Grünen kümmern sich um Verkehr und
Umwelt
wir werden Stück für Stück diese Stadt
umbauen zu einer grüne Rennstart machen
die gerüstet ist für den Klimawandel
mehr Sicherheit für Radfahrer und
Fußgänger wenige Autos besserer
Nahverkehr marode Schulen fehlende
Lehrer in effiziente Verwaltung und
Mangel die Digitalisierung die Aufgaben
sind enorm
Schornsteinfeger so will es die
Tradition in Berlin sollen denn neuen
Glück bringen sie würde es gebrauchen
können
das un Kinderhilfswerk hat zum 22 mal
das UNICEF Foto des Jahres gekürt es
zeigt ein elfjähriges Mädchen in Indien
eine Flutkatastrophe hat den kleinen
teestand von pallavi mitgerissen mit dem
verdiente sie Geld für ihre 5 köpfige
Familie ein foto mit dem UNICEF das Leid
der Kinder angesichts des Klimawandels
in den Mittelpunkt rücken möchte
so wir starten jetzt mit einer super
Leistung und Christin in den Sport echt
beeindruckend das ist unglaublich sagte
Florian Wellbrock nach seinem nahezu
perfekten rennen über 1500m Freistil
Gold bei den Kurzbahn
Weltmeisterschaften in Abu Dhabi mit
Weltrekord besser könnte das ja für den
Freiwasser Olympiasieger nicht zu Ende
gehen das 25m Becken am Persischen Golf
eine Wohlfühloase für Florian Wellbrock
der olympiamedaillengewinner mochte die
Kurzbahn bisher weniger diesmal aber
demonstriert er von Beginn an seine
Überlegenheit mit einem Zwischenspurt
zur Hälfte des Rennens wird das eine
schärfsten Rivalen los den tunesischen
400 m Olympiasieger Haffner und den
Ukraine romantschuk der in Tokio noch
vor ihm gelandet war den Sieg krönt er
mit einem Weltrekord
14688 fast anderthalb Sekunden unter der
alten Bestmarke und mehr als ein Finger
zeigt das Wellbrock bei der nächsten
klassischen Langbahn WM im Mai auch im
Becken nachts greifen will nach Zahl der
Medaillen wird er im deutschen Team aber
noch von Rückenschwimmer Christian
Diener übertroffen beim Sieg des Polen
kawetzki über 200m sichert er sich
Bronze Dieners zweite Medaille nach
Silber über 50 m
und noch zum ski-alpin souveräne
Vorstellung von Mikaela shiffrin beim
zweiten Riesenslalom in diesem Olympia
Winter in Courchevel Frankreich gewann
die Amerikanerin ungefährdet mit einem
Vorsprung von 0,86 Sekunden auf die
zweite Sara Hector aus der Schweiz
deutsche Starterinnen verpassten den
zweiten Lauf für Mikaela shiffrin ist es
bereits der 72 Weltcupsieg ihre Karriere
richtig tolle Frau läuft gut danke
sagen auf jeden Fall das war's von uns
das Wetter gibt's gleich noch von Katja
horneffer und Marietta Slomka begrüßt
sie dann später um 22 Uhr im
heute-journal morgen gerne wieder wenn
Sie mögen und hier geht's jetzt weiter
mit einem ZDF Spezial zu den Corona
Beschlüssen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
guten Abend je mehr sich das Hoch anni
Richtung Südosten verzieht desto mehr
übernimmt das Tief pa allerdings mit
einer milden Südwest Strömung und das
bedeutet für Weihnachten für die meisten
von uns eher Schmuddelwetter heute
brachte hoch Anne ja noch mal viel
Sonnenschein zum Teil hielt sich Nebel
aber auch Zell mich an der Donau oder
auch am Oberrhein und auch in
Norddeutschland gab es einige
Nebelfelder über den Nordosten zogen
dichtere Wolken hinweg und auch in
Nordfriesland gab's dichtere Wolken die
beschäftigungs auch noch in der Nacht
denn da kann es heute Nacht etwas regnen
oder schneien und da wird es glatt auf
den Straßen sonst ist es häufig klar du
nur locker bewirken das bildet sich
wieder neuer Nebel und Dunst bei
Temperaturen die auf null bis -12 Grad
über Schnee am Alpenrand sehen die Werte
morgen liegen wieder um null Grad und
ganz ähnlich wie in der Nacht gibt es
auch morgen noch etwas Regen oder Schnee
im äußersten Norden sonst aber setzt
sich nach Nebel und Dunst häufig die
Sonne durch und spannend denn am
Donnerstag kommt von Westen Regen heran
und wenn der auf den gefrorenen Boden
fällt dann wird es spiegelglatt das gilt
besonders für Nordrhein-Westfalen und
Niedersachsen an Heiligabend wird es
dann meist zu mild sein für Schnee und
das ändert sich dann am ersten Feiertag
guten Abend